Alice:杨老板你还要录一期吗
Alice: Jake, are you going to record another episode?
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:看这一期怎么样
Jake: Let's see how this episode goes.
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Jake:你问我打算我很难回答你
Jake: It's hard for me to answer when you ask about my plans.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Lucia:你问我打算我很难回答你
Lucia: It's hard for me to answer when you ask about my plans.
Alice:懂了懂了
Alice: Got it, got it.
Jake:哈哈哈你问我
Jake: Haha, you ask me.
Jake:下一步有什么打算
Jake: What are your plans for the next step?
Alice:来这里我突然发现我其实并不P
Alice: Coming here, I suddenly realized that I'm actually not P.
Lucia:其实我也觉得
Lucia: Actually, I think so too.
Alice:其实我每天我感觉每天我都在想事情
Alice: Actually, every day I feel like I'm always thinking about things.
Alice:脑子里比较急
Alice: My mind is quite busy.
Alice:呀对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Lucia:对不起对不起
Lucia: Sorry, sorry.
Alice:我 我草
Alice: I... I... damn.
Jake:哎哟哟
Jake: Oh, oh.
Alice:没事它这个石子不是那啥 的
Alice: It's okay, this pebble isn't that bad.
Jake:没事没事没有对对对石子
Jake: It's okay, it's okay, yes, yes, the pebble.
Jake:石头的问题
Jake: It's a stone problem.
Jake:不是您的不是您的问题
Jake: It's not your fault.
Lucia:换个凳子
Lucia: Let's change the stool.
Alice:这晚上坐着还有点冰屁股呢
Alice: Sitting here at night makes my butt a bit cold.
Lucia:是晚上还挺冷的
Lucia: Yes, it's quite cold at night.
Jake:晚上挺冷的 这几天
Jake: It's quite cold at night these days.
Jake:这一周竟然都没有下雨
Jake: This week, it hasn't rained at all.
Jake:有点意思
Jake: Interesting.
Alice:挺好
Alice: That's good.
Jake:北京是这样吗
Jake: Is it like this in Beijing?
Alice:北京下雨本来就不不多
Alice: It doesn't rain much in Beijing.
Lucia:不太多
Lucia: Not that much.
Jake:噢 噢  噢噢
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Alice:嗯但是这几天天气都很好
Alice: Yeah, but the weather has been really nice these days.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Alice:对空气还很好
Alice: And the air quality is pretty good too.
Lucia:所以其实
Lucia: So actually...
Alice:这就不太
Alice: It's not really...
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake:假北京
Jake: Fake Beijing.
Lucia:所以我们其实应该多录点户外的
Lucia: So we should probably shoot more outdoor scenes.
Alice:户外也差不多可以了
Alice: Outdoor is good enough.
Lucia:趁着天气好
Lucia: While the weather is nice.
Jake:对已经加了好几场了 天很少
Jake: Yeah, we've already added quite a few scenes. The weather is rare.
Jake:主要是我不想跑
Jake: Mainly, I don't want to run.
Lucia:加了好几场去超市的吧
Lucia: Added quite a few trips to the supermarket, right?
Jake:对还有别的户外
Jake: Yeah, and other outdoor stuff.
Jake:确实没有
Jake: There's really none.
Jake:那那打的就是抓娃娃
Jake: So the thing is, it's about grabbing dolls.
Jake:那确实很贵对
Jake: It's really expensive.
Alice:啊是
Alice: Oh, yes.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia:呃我又不在你们竞争对手公司是吧
Lucia: I'm not working for your competitor, right?
Lucia:可以放心的给我透露一点
Lucia: You can safely share a bit with me.
Jake:没关系这东西都开源了
Jake: It's okay, it's all open-source.
Jake:过两个月啥也没
Jake: After a couple of months, there'll be nothing.
Jake:对嗯我不知道
Jake: Yeah, I don't know.
Jake:不是不是我大概知道
Jake: No, no, I kind of know.
Jake:是说里边他们会抓一个娃娃对吧
Jake: They will grab a doll inside, right?
Jake:最后他不是以前不是抓那个娃娃吗
Jake: In the past, they used to grab the doll, right?
Jake:然后那个娃娃可能就能在某一个时间
Jake: And that doll might be at a certain point in time.
Jake:有一个年纪
Jake: At a certain age.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:是娃娃岛来的呀
Jake: It's from Doll Island.
Jake:然后就可以倒到那个时间点去
Jake: And then it can travel to that point in time.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia:那如果没抓上呢
Lucia: What if it doesn't catch?
Jake:没抓上没抓上我就会有别的解释
Jake: If it doesn't catch, I have another explanation.
Alice:比如说
Alice: For example...
Jake:不知道啊现在不是我不知道
Jake: I don't know, I really don't know right now.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Lucia:好有意思啊
Lucia: This is so interesting.
Lucia:这是这是正常的么
Lucia: Is this, is this normal?
Lucia:这真是
Lucia: This is really...
Lucia:这是应该的
Lucia: This is how it should be.
Alice:这是这是可以的
Alice: This is, this is actually fine.
Alice:这竟然是可以的
Alice: This is actually allowed?
Alice:给了一个很真诚但是感觉不太真诚回答
Alice: He gave a sincere but insincere answer.
Jake:就是
Jake: Exactly.
Lucia:他经常说出一些
Lucia: He often says things...
Lucia:我觉得好像是在忽悠我们
Lucia: I feel like he's just fooling us.
Lucia:但是这才是真的话
Lucia: But that's actually the truth.
Alice:但是这才是真的话
Alice: But that's actually the truth.
Lucia:我觉得你才应该去玩那个四真两假
Lucia: I think you should play that game, "Four truths and two lies."
Lucia:那个
Lucia: That one.
Alice:对啊
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:噢 噢
Jake: Oh, oh.
Lucia:你就光把你记好的那个大家觉得肯定是编的
Lucia: You just remember the ones everyone thinks are made up.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Alice:p到如此地步
Alice: Photoshopped to this extent?
Alice:这是
Alice: This is...
Lucia:这是可以的吗
Lucia: Is this allowed?
Alice:我现在就改换人格
Alice: I'm going to change my personality now.
Jake:做科研嘛
Jake: Doing research...
Jake:就是要探索
Jake: It's all about exploration.
Alice:哈哈我现在就改换人格了
Alice: Haha, I'm changing my personality now.
Alice:脱下我的ENMP面具
Alice: Taking off my ENMP mask.
Jake:你们J很多啊
Jake: You guys have a lot of J's.
Jake:你们这些J人
Jake: You J people.
Lucia:我真的是偏远
Lucia: I'm really remote.
Lucia:不知为何我总觉得哪里有点怪怪的
Lucia: For some reason, I always feel something is off.
Lucia:我们不会真的在传销组织吧
Lucia: Are we really in a pyramid scheme?
Alice:这是啥呀 刘婷
Alice: What is this, Liu Ting?
Alice:又是 哦 葱
Alice: Again, oh, scallions.
Jake:来来来
Jake: Come on, come on.
Alice:我今天吃的时候甚至都没吃葱
Alice: I didn't even eat scallions today.
Lucia:不是干吃吗
Lucia: Aren't we just eating them dry?
Alice:比萨卷葱中西合壁了
Alice: The pizza has become a fusion of Chinese and Western.
Lucia:所以被吃掉的那些东西他也可以
Lucia: So, those things that were eaten, he can also...
Jake:对吃掉的这些东西
Jake: Yeah, all these things we've eaten
Jake:他也可以 他也可以 怎么
Jake: He can also... he can also... how to...
Jake:可以和
Jake: Can be with...
Lucia:它就跟娃娃机一个道理吗
Lucia: Is it just like a claw machine?
Jake:吃掉的这些东西
Jake: All these things we've eaten
Jake:这也不是
Jake: This isn't...
Jake:就是这些
Jake: It's just these
Jake:可能吃披萨这种活动呢
Jake: Maybe activities like eating pizza
Jake:刚刚我们也没怎么好好录
Jake: We didn't record them well earlier
Jake:但是就是说是前一段和后一段
Jake: But it's like the part before and after
Jake:中间有个尬舞
Jake: In the middle there's an awkward dance
Jake:然后但是
Jake: But then
Jake:你们可能就是我们现在录的这些东西
Jake: You guys might be like, what we are recording now
Jake:然后就就有一个问
Jake: And then there's a question
Jake:就是
Jake: Like
Jake:就问AI说我们刚刚可能干一些什么事情
Jake: Asking AI what we might have been doing earlier
Jake:在一个空余的时间里面
Jake: In some spare time
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh
Alice:那最后我们那个每个人的行动路线
Alice: Then in the end, each of our action routes
Alice:会会显示每个人偏好干嘛
Alice: Will show what each person prefers to do
Jake:这个应该很容易
Jake: This should be easy
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia:那会显示每个人偏好干嘛
Lucia: Then it will show what each person prefers to do
Alice:我偏好洗衣服
Alice: I prefer to do laundry
Alice:哈哈哈我每天都把油弄在衣服上
Alice: Hahaha, I get oil on my clothes every day
Jake:对 你如果
Jake: Yeah, if you...
Alice:每天都在洗衣服
Alice: Washing clothes every day
Jake:对你带着眼镜一直洗衣服啊
Jake: Yeah, you wear glasses and keep doing laundry
Jake:确实知道你是洗衣服干啥
Jake: Of course we know you do laundry
Alice:对然后我一直在擦擦桌子
Alice: Yeah, and I keep wiping the table
Lucia:哦靠
Lucia: Oh my god
Jake:啊 这个没问题 对
Jake: Ah, no problem, yeah
Katrina: 那他为什么老要加一个
Katrina: Then why does he always need to add one more
Lucia:主要是研究者不好研究我这些
Lucia: Mainly the researchers can't study me well
Alice:无所谓
Alice: It doesn't matter
Jake:啥啥啥
Jake: What, what, what
Lucia:主要是研究者不知道这个人是我就行
Lucia: As long as the researchers don't know it's me, it's fine
Jake:OKOK
Jake: OK, OK
Alice:我无所谓
Alice: I don't care
Alice:那那是不是我们就要那个
Alice: Then, then does it mean we have to...
Lucia:要不然它就会发现我经常在摸鱼
Lucia: Otherwise, it'll find out that I often slack off.
Jake:那这个太常见了
Jake: That's too common.
Jake:哈哈哈这是人类本质
Jake: Haha, that's human nature.
Alice:那我们这个什么
Alice: What about this...
Lucia:人类的本质是摸鱼 好 不是
Lucia: Human nature is slacking off. Okay, no...
Alice:你说啥来着
Alice: What were you saying?
Alice:坏了 找不着了
Alice: Oh no, I can't find it.
Alice:真找不着了
Alice: Really can't find it.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Alice:忘了说一半忘了
Alice: Forgot, I forgot halfway through.
Alice:坏了
Alice:难受啊我现在很难受
Alice: I feel so uncomfortable right now.
Lucia:没事 你学学领导
Lucia: It's okay, just learn from the boss.
Jake:想一想想一想想一想
Jake: Think, think, think.
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:想不起来
Jake: Can't remember.
Jake:不想了吧
Jake: Just forget it.
Lucia:你看
Lucia: Look.
Shure: 下来下来下来
Shure: Come down, come down.
Tasha:怎么又下来了都
Tasha: Why did everyone come down again?
Jake:想不起来
Jake: Can't remember.
Jake:过两分钟就想起来了
Jake: You'll remember in a couple of minutes.
Lucia:要是过两分钟也想不起来那就
Lucia: If I still can't remember in a couple of minutes then...
Jake:那就忘掉
Jake: Then just forget it.
Alice:啊对对对别别别
Alice: Ah, right, right, no, no, no.
Alice:就是我们这个
Alice: So, this...
Alice:最后那个每个人的数据还会让自己看
Alice: In the end, everyone can see their own data.
Alice:就是需要什么删什么或者之类的
Alice: So you can delete whatever you need or something like that.
Jake:对我们会帮你们先删
Jake: Yeah, we'll help you delete it first.
Jake:我回头给你们
Jake: I'll give it to you later.
Lucia:领导你没给我看
Lucia: Boss, you didn't show it to me.
Lucia:就是到达的那个视频
Lucia: The video of the arrival.
Lucia:你忘记了
Lucia: You forgot.
Jake:啊就今天的这个
Jake: Oh, today's one?
Alice:我是不是没有到达的视频
Alice: Do I not have the arrival video?
Lucia:太皮了嗯
Lucia: You're too naughty, hmm?
Jake:就是到达的视频
Jake: The arrival video.
Jake:就是今天放的那个
Jake: The one we played today.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:我我是不是没有到达
Alice: Do I not have the arrival...
Lucia:太P了
Lucia: That's too fake.
Lucia:但是这才是真的话
Lucia: But that's the truth.
Jake:你没有到达的视频
Jake: You didn't get the video.
Jake:因为他们没有录
Jake: Because they didn't record it.
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake.
Lucia:一般如果有志愿者去接你的话就有
Lucia: Usually, if there's a volunteer to pick you up, then there is.
Shure: 该把这也开了吧
Shure: Should we turn this on too?
Alice:有但但没有录
Alice: There is, but it wasn't recorded.
Jake:开开开开
Jake: Turn it on, turn it on.
Alice:我以为录了无所谓
Alice: I thought it was recorded, no big deal.
Shure: 我把他们都叫下来
Shure: I'll call everyone down.
Shure: 然后咱开一个
Shure: Then we'll start one.
Jake:哎好
Jake: Okay, sure.
Alice:来听响了
Alice: Listen to the sound.
Shure: ego life圆满收官
Shure: Ego life is coming to a perfect end.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Alice:明天打扫卫生
Alice: Cleaning up tomorrow.
Shure: 快快快快下来下来下来下来来
Shure: Quick, quick, quick, come down, come down, come down.
Lucia:收拾收拾尾声
Lucia: Wrapping things up.
Alice:这粉底都擦掉了
Alice: My foundation is all rubbed off.
Lucia:一般在我们宿舍
Lucia: Usually in our dorm.
Lucia:收拾收拾尾声的意思是
Lucia: Wrapping things up means.
Lucia:这剩一块披萨的感觉
Lucia: It's like having one piece of pizza left.
Lucia:收拾收拾尾声
Lucia: Wrapping things up.
Jake:那他压力挺大的
Jake: That puts a lot of pressure on him.
Alice:受不了 刘婷 解决一下
Alice: Can't take it, Liu Ting, handle it.
刘婷:干啥
Liu Ting: What?
Alice:解决一下
Alice: Handle it.
Lucia:收拾收拾尾声哈哈哈
Lucia: Wrapping things up, hahaha.
Jake:所以今天的那个视频要调点角度
Jake: So, today's video needs some angle adjustment.
Jake:还是什么
Jake: Or what?
Lucia:我还没看呢
Lucia: I haven't seen it yet.
Jake:你还没看到呢
Jake: You haven't seen it yet?
Alice:嗯没关系大家已经看了
Alice: It's okay, everyone has already seen it.
Lucia:嗯 你没放
Lucia: Yeah, you didn't post it.
Jake:放话太早了是吧
Jake: Did I speak too soon?
Lucia:对放的是我还在
Lucia: Yeah, you posted while I was still...
Lucia:我咱俩是不是都没看
Lucia: Neither of us saw it, right?
Jake:行行行
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia:咱俩在下面我记得
Lucia: We were downstairs, I remember.
Alice:对我没有看到
Alice: Yeah, I didn't see it.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake:拿出来看看
Jake: Take it out and have a look.
Jake:共赏佳叫什么
Jake: What's the name of this beautiful thing?
Alice:感我能吃口又不想吃口
Alice: I feel like I want to eat but don't want to eat.
Lucia:我也 其是我是有点想吃 但是有点不想吃
Lucia: Me too. Actually, I kinda want to eat but also kinda don't want to.
Alice:但是
Alice: But...
Alice:觉得扔了比较可惜
Alice: It feels like a waste to throw it away.
Lucia:其实我们第二天又会买买买然后就是
Lucia: Actually, we end up buying more the next day anyway.
Alice:我们我们每天的剩饭就是放冰箱
Alice: We always put the leftovers in the fridge.
Alice:然后第二天把冰箱里的 不是
Alice: Then the next day, we... no.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:然后把冰箱里的东西丢掉
Alice: Then we throw away the stuff in the fridge.
Lucia:因为剩的如果大家一起吃的话就不够
Lucia: Because if everyone eats the leftovers together, it's not enough.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia:这肯定会点新的
Lucia: We definitely order new food.
Lucia:但是一点新的光吃新的就够
Lucia: But eating only the new food is enough.
Alice:然后
Alice: Then...
Alice:然后新的又剩哈哈哈
Alice: Then the new food has leftovers again, haha.
Lucia:最后麻烦
Lucia: It's a hassle in the end.
Alice:要不留两块你当夜宵吃
Alice: How about you keep a couple of pieces for a midnight snack?
Alice:你晚上睡得晚吗你
Alice: You stay up late, right?
Alice:挺晚的你两点还给我发抖音
Alice: You were still sending me TikToks at 2 AM.
Alice:真服了
Alice: Seriously.
Lucia:你们是舍友还是
Lucia: Are you guys roommates or...?
Alice:不是她是我的老公
Alice: No, she's my husband.
Lucia:也可可可以有
Lucia: Well, can be...
Alice:就是好朋友
Alice: Just good friends.
Alice:哎这个是啥呀
Alice: Hey, what is this?
Lucia:这应该是薇薇的小旗子吧
Lucia: This should be Tasha's little flag, right?
Alice:这
Alice: This...
Alice:哦那可能是
Alice: Oh, maybe.
Alice:这是谁的快递，有拆没
Shure: 来来来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure: 一起一起来
Shure: Let's do this together.
Alice:这空的吗
Alice: Is this empty?
Alice:有东西不知道是啥
Alice: There's something inside but I don't know what it is.
Lucia:所以你是他的老公吗
Lucia: So are you her husband?
Alice:不是不是不是
Alice: No, no, no.
Lucia:我开玩笑的啦
Lucia: Just kidding.
Alice:我
Alice: I
Shure: 小心崩到你的电脑哦
Shure: Be careful not to spill it on your computer
Jake: 好嘞 我们先开香槟
Jake: Alright, let's open the champagne first
Alice:让我来录一下
Alice: Let me record it
Lucia:我开玩笑的
Lucia: I was joking
Lucia:开玩笑的
Lucia: Just kidding
Alice:好
Alice: Okay
Alice:321 哎
Alice: 3, 2, 1, hey
Alice:让大家都出来
Alice: Get everyone out here
Alice:9点了
Alice: It's 9 o'clock
Shure: 他是不是偷偷说我坏话呢
Shure: Is he secretly talking bad about me?
Jake:手舞足蹈说你坏话
Jake: He's animatedly talking bad about you
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh no
Alice:找个想吃的味道吧
Alice: Find a flavor you want to eat
Alice:我不想吃这个带香肠的
Alice: I don't want the one with sausage
Lucia:这个叫
Lucia: This is called
Lucia:苏米  萨萨拉米 应该是萨拉米
Lucia: Sumi, Salami, it should be salami
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Lucia:不过我不确定国内萨拉米正宗不正宗
Lucia: But I'm not sure if it's authentic in China
Alice:没有我想吃的
Alice: They don't have what I want
Lucia:但是没关系 好吃就行
Lucia: But it doesn't matter, as long as it's tasty
Alice:全都有这个香肠
Alice: Everything has sausage
Lucia:对你把香肠掑下来又不吃
Lucia: Just take the sausage off and don't eat it
Alice:那今天吃什么明天都一陀屎呢你咋不说呢
Alice: Whatever we eat today, it's all going to be crap tomorrow, why don't you say that
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting
Alice:我怎么了
Alice: What's wrong with me
Alice:不管它就这样
Alice: Never mind, just leave it
Alice:能不能帮我吃一顿
Alice: Can you help me eat this
刘婷:什么叫帮你吃一顿
Liu Ting: What do you mean help you eat
刘婷:你不是自己想吃吗
Liu Ting: Didn't you want to eat it yourself
Alice:还是选了这个香肠的
Alice: Still chose the one with sausage
Lucia:帮他收拾一下尾声
Lucia: Help him clean up the mess
Alice:吃不吃
Alice: Eat it or not
Alice:沙子
Alice: Sand
Alice:比如
Alice: For example
Jack: 这个拍短袖敬请期待啊
Jack: Stay tuned for this short sleeve filming
Jack: 期待
Jack: Stay tuned
Katrina: 怎么焦点一下转到我身上来
Katrina: Why is the focus suddenly on me
Jack: 这个这个事情很显然啊
Jack: This is very obvious
Jack: 这个事就是很
Jack: This thing is very
就是现在那个男生一定觉得
So right now that guy must be thinking
Nicous: 如果你后面还跟他去正常联系
Nicous: If you keep in touch with him normally later
Nicous: 他就会觉得这个人怎么一直吊着
Nicous: He'll think why is this person still hanging around
Nicous: 有没有一种可能
Nicous: Could it be possible
Nicous: 你觉得那些好兄弟都不喜欢你
Nicous: You think your good buddies don't like you
Nicous: 所以你觉得无所谓
Nicous: So you don't care
Jack: 对啊或他们就他们觉得对啊但是
Jack: Yeah, or they just think, yeah, but
Nicous: 正好这个男的喜欢就一样了
Nicous: Just so happens that this guy likes you, so it's the same
Katrina: 所以他觉得在他的视角
Katrina: So he thinks from his perspective
Katrina: 我邀请他就代表我喜欢他
Katrina: If I invite him, it means I like him
Nicous: 对而且而且
Nicous: Yeah, and also
Nicous: 重点问题是我今天下午才坐到你旁边
Nicous: The main issue is I just sat next to you this afternoon
Katrina: 什么逻辑
Katrina: What kind of logic is that
Lucia:什么逻辑
Lucia: What kind of logic is that
Nicous: 你们俩就那样
Nicous: You two were just like that
Nicous: 硬坐了一下午
Nicous: Sitting awkwardly all afternoon
Nicous: 对啊哈哈哈
Nicous: Yeah, haha
Katrina: 他都坐过来了我能跑吗
Katrina: He came over to sit, could I run away?
Nicous: 那你应该喊那你应该喊一个董超超
Nicous: Then you should have called Jack
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jack: 你没看我当时不往那坐吗
Jack: Didn't you see I didn't sit there?
Katrina: 坐我俩中间吗
Katrina: Sit between the two of us?
Jack: 我当时都走了呀
Jack: I left at that time
Jack: 我本来坐在这
Jack: I was originally sitting here
Katrina: 你怎么一言不发就开呢
Katrina: Why did you start without saying anything
Katrina: 就开呢还没录呢
Katrina: Start recording without telling us
Nicous: 对啊
Nicous: Yeah
男嘉宾:我给你塞回去
Male Guest: I'll put it back for you
男嘉宾:你重新再开一遍
Male Guest: You start it again
Jack: 你再开一回吧
Jack: You start it again
Jack: 没摇吧
Jack: Didn't shake it, right?
Lucia:塞回去气不够了
Lucia: Put it back, there's not enough air
Shure: 我摇了我真摇了
Shure: I shook it, I really shook it
Jack: 多摇点再来一回再
Jack: Shake it more, let's do it again
Shure: 在
Shure: Okay
Shure: 再来一条
Shure: Let's do another one
Shure: 这玩意怎么塞回去啊 哥
Shure: How do you put this thing back in, bro
Jake:他 他是
Jake: He, he is
Lucia:外面还挺冷的
Lucia: It's quite cold outside
Jake:他是谁啊
Jake: Who is he?
男嘉宾:哎是那天这个还有个塞
Male Guest: Oh, that day, there was also a plug.
Jake:哎呀 我草
Jake: Oh my god, damn it.
Shure: 我把还有几个
Shure: I have a few more.
Lucia:我把洗
Lucia: I'll wash it.
Lucia:明天有什么
Lucia: What's tomorrow?
Lucia:有雨
Lucia: It's going to rain.
Katrina: 就是男女对唱
Katrina: It's a duet.
Katrina: 他非要我看他的眼睛
Katrina: He insists I look into his eyes.
Shure: 嘬一口吧
Shure: Take a sip.
Nicous: 因为如果因为如果他真的很
Nicous: Because if he really...
Alice:吃什么瓜
Alice: What are we eating?
Lucia:我把它这个烟抽一根算了
Lucia: I'll just smoke one.
Shure: 真的懒得刷了拿纸杯吧
Shure: I'm really too lazy to wash it, let's use a paper cup.
Lucia:算了
Lucia: Forget it.
Shure: 可以用纸杯了吗
Shure: Can we use paper cups now?
Jake:可以可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes, we can.
Shure: 走了
Shure: Let's go.
Jack: 走掉了
Jack: Left already.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Shure的女友:他真的有
Shure's GF: He really has...
Shure的女友:就是他整个人注意力都在
Shure's GF: His whole attention is on...
Nicous: 不是你哦
Nicous: Not you.
Jack: 就是这个点
Jack: It's just this point.
Nicous: 你找男生
Nicous: You're looking for a guy.
Katrina: 他没有普通朋友
Katrina: He has no ordinary friends.
Shure的女友:就那天
Shure's GF: Just that day...
Nicous: 没出的问题
Nicous: There wasn't a problem.
Lucia:我也没吃上啊
Lucia: I didn't get to eat either.
Nicous: 是他出问题
Nicous: He's the one with the problem.
Lucia:咱们不是在这外边耍
Lucia: We weren't playing outside here.
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: ego life
Shure: Ego life.
Jake:哎大卖大卖
Jake: Hey, big sale, big sale.
Shure: 大卖了
Shure: Big sale.
Shure: 圆满结束了
Shure: Perfect ending.
Shure: 基本上
Shure: Basically.
Shure: 他在开车呢
Shure: He's driving.
Nicous: 解说是
Nicous: The commentary is...
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Lucia: 谁要开车
Lucia: Who's going to drive?
Lucia:你要开车啊
Lucia: Are you driving?
Alice:嗯干嘛
Alice: Uh, what's up?
Jake:那你喝点橙汁吧
Jake: Then have some orange juice.
女嘉宾:可惜了啊
Female Guest: What a pity.
Jake:要不
Jake: Or...
Nicous: 没事没事
Nicous: It's fine, it's fine.
Lucia:可惜了了
Lucia: What a pity.
Alice:啊来吧
Alice: Ah, come on.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Alice:破 破戒了
Alice: Broke my vow.
Lucia:农夫微醺水
Lucia: Farmer's light drink.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:哈哈哈可以可以
Jake: Haha, nice, nice.
Shure: 来点吧路亚
Shure: Have some, Lucia.
Jake:嗯好的
Jake: Yeah, sure.
Lucia:啊 好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Shure: 客气
Shure: You're welcome.
Shure的女友:觉得啊这个人好像对我有意思
Shure's GF: I feel like this person is interested in me.
Shure的女友:那种男生你都可以归为
Shure's GF: You can categorize such guys as...
Lucia:哇好多泡泡
Lucia: Wow, so many bubbles.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Alice:这多少度啊
Alice: What's the alcohol content?
Nicous: 喝出了粮食酒的感觉
Nicous: Tastes like grain alcohol.
Lucia:气泡酒可能一般11-15左右
Lucia: Sparkling wine is usually around 11-15%.
Shure: 11
Shure: 11.
Alice:这么辣吗
Alice: Is it that strong?
Alice:我现在口味这么淡吗
Alice: Is my tolerance that low now?
Shure: 11.5对 不它
Shure: 11.5, yeah. No, it's...
Alice:才十来度
Alice: Just around 10 degrees.
Jake:来来敬敬敬
Jake: Come on, cheers, cheers, cheers.
女嘉宾:怎么
Female Guest: What?
Jake:你的好朋友来
Jake: Your good friend is here.
Alice:感觉我退化了吗
Alice: Do I feel like I'm regressing?
Shure: 来一杯
Shure: Have a drink.
Alice:可能吧我已经很久不喝酒了哦
Alice: Maybe. I haven't drunk in a long time.
Alice:你倒点吧
Alice: Pour some for yourself.
Nicous: 我不要
Nicous: I don't want any.
Jack: 我晚上开车呢
Jack: I'm driving tonight.
Alice:那你拿个这干啥
Alice: Then why did you take this?
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Lucia:一点撤不开
Lucia: It can't be moved at all.
Alice:神经
Alice: Nonsense.
Shure: 还有谁没有吗
Shure: Is there anyone who doesn't have one?
Shure: OK都有了吧
Shure: OK, does everyone have one now?
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 你你你来一杯吗
Shure: Do you want a drink?
女嘉宾:不用不用
Female Guest: No, no.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Alice:我那啥了
Alice: I did that.
Shure: 我们举杯敬
Shure: Let's raise our glasses.
Shure: 敬ego来来先先敬ego life一杯
Shure: Cheers to ego, come on, cheers to ego life.
Shure: 然后再再说这个来
Shure: Then we'll talk about this, come on.
Shure: 哈哈哈来来来ego life哎
Shure: Hahaha come on, come on, ego life, yay.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay!
男嘉宾: 好
Male Guest: Good.
刘婷:没事还会有还会有
Liu Ting: It's okay, there will be more.
Shure: 谁问的倒吗
Shure: Who asked for a refill?
Lucia:还有还有
Lucia: There's more, more.
Lucia:没倒完呢
Lucia: It's not finished yet.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Jake:说到哪了
Jake: Where were we?
Alice:不好喝
Katrina: 我我真的很想知道
Katrina: I, I really want to know.
Katrina: 那他11月份的时候跟我分开
Katrina: When he broke up with me in November.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Katrina: 分开就这样拥抱一下
Katrina: We just hugged like this.
Katrina: 我以为是礼节
Katrina: I thought it was a formality.
Katrina: 就是有一种意思
Katrina: It felt like it meant something.
Nicous: 谁跟暧昧拥抱一下
Nicous: Who hugs ambiguously?
Nicous: 不会的不会的
Nicous: No way, no way.
Nicous: 绝对不会
Nicous: Absolutely not.
Jack: 这国内啊
Jack: This is in the country.
Katrina: 没有就是就是
Katrina: No, it's just...
Katrina: 我感觉这张脸不是啊
Katrina: I feel like this face isn't...
Jack: 这国内啊
Jack: This is in the country.
Alice:我去我要吃这个
Alice: Wow, I want to eat this.
Alice:你给我分一下
Alice: Share some with me.
Shure的女友:你觉得OK
Shure's GF: Do you think it's OK?
Shure的女友:他可能有点暧昧
Shure's GF: He might be a bit ambiguous.
Lucia:我吃
Lucia: I'll eat.
Shure的女友:你就可以把他归到啊
Shure's GF: You can just categorize him as...
Lucia:但我想进微波炉打一下
Lucia: But I want to heat it in the microwave.
Shure的女友:因为
Shure's GF: Because...
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Lucia:你可以先撕给我
Lucia: Can you tear it for me first?
Jack: 你这还明显
Jack: This is still obvious.
Lucia:然后我帮你们都打一下
Lucia: Then I'll heat it for everyone.
Jack: 分开的时候拥抱一下
Jack: Hug each other when separating.
Alice:吃凉的
Alice: Eat it cold.
Jack: 生病的时候给你买药
Jack: Buy you medicine when you're sick.
Lucia:因为外边太冷了
Lucia: Because it's too cold outside.
Jack: 今天过去坐你旁边啊
Jack: Sit next to you today.
今Jack: 天今天就是今天
Jack: Today is today.
Jack: 这一天你生病了还给你买药
Jack: On this day, you were sick and he bought you medicine.
Lucia:大的吃不完 哦算了没事
Lucia: It's too big to finish. Oh, never mind.
Katrina: 他坐我旁边
Katrina: He sat next to me.
Lucia:反正就算我吃不完
Lucia: Even if I can't finish it...
Katrina: 好奇怪我都我一个人坐在那
Katrina: So weird, I was sitting there alone.
Lucia:别人应该也也也吃不完
Lucia: Others probably can't finish it either.
Katrina: 他非要从凳子上坐过来
Katrina: He insisted on sitting over from his chair.
Jack: 生病给你买药还不奇怪吗
Jack: Isn't it strange to buy you medicine when you're sick?
女嘉宾:盖死都怪怪
Female Guest: It's all strange.
Lucia:我我拿哪个
Lucia: Which one should I take?
Shure的女友:这还不能说明问题吗
Shure's GF: Doesn't this explain everything?
Lucia:这这个就刚放这是吧
Lucia: This one, that was just put here, right?
Jack: 对啊盖死的全在凳子上
Jack: Yes, all of them on the chair.
Lucia:嗯我去拿这盘
Lucia: Hmm, I'll take this plate.
Shure: 我天啊 你的
Shure: Oh my gosh, yours...
Jake: 是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:拿个纸 刘婷
Alice: Get some paper, Liu Ting.
Shure:  AI能分析明白这个吗
Shure: Can AI understand this?
Alice:纸
Alice: Paper.
Jake: 我觉得能
Jake: I think it can.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh no.
Jake:我觉得AI已经能分析明白
Jake: I think AI can already understand this.
Alice:给这来给这来 哎呀
Alice: Give it here, give it here, oh dear.
Shure: AI能分清明白你这个是吗
Shure: Can AI tell the difference in this?
Jake:您这得 它得他得训练训练你
Jake: It needs... it needs to train you.
Alice:哎哟
Alice: Ouch
Jack: 我感觉我们几个毛都已经能推测出来
Jack: I feel like we can already guess everything
Jake:他得训一训的得训一训
Jake: He needs to be trained, needs to be trained
Jack: 到时候我们给它
Jack: Then we'll give it to him
男嘉宾:从这两个人是什么关系
Male Guest: What's the relationship between these two people
男嘉宾:从他的描述来看
Male Guest: Based on his description
男嘉宾:这两个人很有可能是情侣关系
Male Guest: It's very likely these two are in a relationship
Jack: 嗯对
Jack: Hmm, right
Jack: 要给派的DVT
Jack: Gotta give them a DVT
Jack: 估计能行啊
Jack: Probably will work
Jack: 我我我们来看
Jack: Let's see
Jack: 说到照片
Jack: Speaking of photos
男嘉宾:来来来搞个
Male Guest: Come on, let's do one
Jake:唉
Jake: Hey
Jack: 来大家来照照照片
Jack: Come on, everyone, let's take a photo
Shure: 还要吗
Shure: Do we need more?
Alice:干嘛
Alice: Why?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Jack: 哇拍这么多呀拍这么多拍这么多
Jack: Wow, taking so many, taking so many, taking so many
刘婷:这是一只这是一只孔雀
Liu Ting: This is a peacock
Nicous: 拍这么多可以啊
Nicous: Taking so many is fine
Katrina: 他让他拍的呀
Katrina: He asked for them
Jack: 我靠他们给他拍太爽了
Jack: Wow, they took so many for him, so nice
Alice:我让你拍一个啊
Alice: I asked you to take one
Alice:我真服了你
Alice: I'm really impressed
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting
刘婷:这是一只孔雀
Liu Ting: This is a peacock
Alice:我靠 我真服了
Alice: Wow, I'm really impressed
刘婷:然后他今天
Liu Ting: And today he
Alice:然后呢
Alice: And then?
刘婷:然后呢然后他发烧了
Liu Ting: And then he had a fever
刘婷:他咳嗽然后嗯
Liu Ting: He coughed, and hmm
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Jack: 这个我感觉
Jack: I feel like
Alice:继续等一下
Alice: Keep waiting
Alice:行他今天咳嗽
Alice: Okay, he coughed today
Alice:他今天怎么咳嗽
Alice: How did he cough today?
刘婷:他今天生病了
Liu Ting: He got sick today
Alice:生病
Alice: Sick
刘婷:他是一只落汤凤凰
Liu Ting: He looks like a drenched phoenix.
Shure: 没有啊
Shure: No, he doesn't.
Alice:我真服了啊
Alice: I'm really impressed.
Alice:弱智吧
Alice: Is he an idiot?
Jake:我得行
Jake: I think I can do it.
Alice:不用我要公放
Alice: No, I need it on speaker.
Shure的女友:你把他赶走了
Shure's GF: You drove him away.
Jake:拍照挺
Jake: Take a picture.
Jake:我觉得这张照片还行
Jake: I think this photo is okay.
Shure: 什么叫赶走
Shure: What do you mean by drove away?
Jake:多拍几张应该就BIOS
Jake: Take a few more shots, it should be good.
Shure的女友:你把他赶走了
Shure's GF: You drove him away.
Shure: 不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Katrina: 不然他老坐我旁边
Katrina: Otherwise, he'd always sit next to me.
Shure: 再说再说
Shure: Let's talk about it later.
Katrina: 我看不到他们的摄像头
Katrina: I can't see their camera.
Alice:不行来个完整版的快点
Alice: No, let's have the full version, quickly.
刘婷:OK  please
Liu Ting: OK, please.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on.
Alice:生呢
Alice: Live?
Alice:能不能快点啊 最好十十
Alice: Can you be quicker? Preferably within ten seconds.
Alice:最好是能不能10秒钟之内给我解决了
Alice: Could you solve it within 10 seconds?
刘婷:ok
Liu Ting: OK.
Alice:来吧这是一只
Alice: Come on, this is one.
刘婷:这是一只凤凰嗯
Liu Ting: This is a phoenix, yeah.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
刘婷:今天的淋雨感冒了
Liu Ting: It got rained on and caught a cold today.
刘婷:所以他咳嗽了
Liu Ting: So it's coughing.
刘婷:他变成了一只落汤凤凰
Liu Ting: It turned into a drenched phoenix.
刘婷:没了没了
Liu Ting: That's it, that's it.
Alice:没了
Alice: That's it.
刘婷:10秒钟之内吗
Liu Ting: Within 10 seconds, right?
Shure的女友:就是啊OK
Shure's GF: Exactly, OK.
Shure的女友:就是一个什么北欧的男生
Shure's GF: It's just some Nordic guy.
Alice:弱智
Alice: Idiot.
Shure: 那那是另一个
Shure: That was another one.
Lucia:我想再来一点
Lucia: I want a bit more.
Alice:我确实不美
Alice: I'm really not beautiful.
Shure的女友:我现在知道了
Shure's GF: Now I know.
Shure的女友:然后当时我来的时候
Shure's GF: When I came at that time...
Lucia:你要吃吗
Lucia: Do you want to eat?
Katrina: 我以为是我是捂得高高的
Katrina: I thought it was me holding it high.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Huh?
Jake:那确实
Jake: That's true.
那确实
That's true.
Katrina: 我感觉你耳朵这样
Katrina: I feel like your ears are like this.
Shure的女友:然后然后当时看到
Guest: And then at that time, I saw...
Shure的女友:我以为是你把他约出来了
Guest: I thought you invited him out.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure的女友:因为那个不敢约
Guest: Because he didn't dare to ask.
Lucia:我现在特别好奇
Lucia: Now I'm really curious.
Lucia:他原本不切开会有多大
Lucia: How big would it have been if it wasn't cut open?
Nicous: 有胆小鬼
Nicous: Such a coward.
Shure的女友:奥然哈哈
Guest: Oh, right. Haha.
Jake:为啥
Jake: Why?
Lucia:没有看到他那造型
Lucia: Didn't you see his style?
Shure: 你约他一顿饭呢
Shure: Did you invite him for a meal?
Shure的女友:约出来了
Guest: Invited.
Alice:我呢
Alice: What about me?
Jack: 哦靠 cp cp
Jack: Oh, damn, CP CP.
刘婷:它嗓子比较痒哦
Liu Ting: His throat is a bit itchy.
刘婷:然后他就他就他就吃了一个泡椒鸡
Liu Ting: Then he ate a pickled pepper chicken.
Shure的女友:什么结婚照
Guest: What wedding photo?
刘婷:泡椒凤爪
Liu Ting: Pickled chicken feet.
刘婷:去里面挠了一下喉咙
Liu Ting: Scratched his throat with it.
Nicous: 你就给爽到了到
Nicous: You just enjoyed it.
嘉宾:第二张照片发给这男的
Guest: Sent the second photo to this guy.
嘉宾:他直接作壁纸了
Guest: He made it his wallpaper right away.
男嘉宾:对他他他直接就就就
Male Guest: Yeah, he just...
男嘉宾:颅内高潮颅内高潮
Male Guest: Brain orgasm, brain orgasm.
Shure的女友:我我真的感觉
Guest: I really felt...
Shure的女友:就是当时看到你们俩的状态
Guest: When I saw the state you two were in...
Shure的女友:我以为他是那个人
Guest: I thought he was that person.
Lucia:哎好看
Lucia: Oh, nice.
Shure的女友:然后我说呃OK
Guest: Then I said, uh, OK.
Shure的女友:可能这个人
Guest: Maybe this person...
Katrina: 可是我对他没有那种很主动的行为
Katrina: But I didn't have that kind of active behavior towards him.
刘婷:这个不会也被录下来了吧
Liu Ting: This won't be recorded too, right?
男嘉宾:来来来
Male Guest: Come on, come on.
Katrina: 我都没跟他说什么话呀
Katrina: I didn't say anything to him.
Jake:内部数据
Jake: Internal data
Jack: 分析一下
Jack: Analyze it
Alice:肯定啊 这眼镜呢
Alice: Of course, where are the glasses?
女嘉宾:我觉得挺正常的
Female Guest: I think it's pretty normal.
Katrina: 因为我觉得因为我觉得尴尬了
Katrina: Because I think it's awkward.
女嘉宾:我觉得挺正常的
Female Guest: I think it's pretty normal.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: Whatever
Jack: 不知道我们这属于这一段
Jack: I don't know if this part belongs to us.
Alice:人工智能真的会不理解你在干什么
Alice: AI really doesn't understand what you're doing.
Jack: 属于因号此类吧
Jack: It probably belongs to this category.
男嘉宾:可能正常的就是这个图片组
Male Guest: Maybe the normal one is this set of pictures.
Shure的女友:无所谓
Shure's GF: Whatever
女嘉宾:平等的撞死所有人
Female Guest: Equality crashes everyone.
Shure的女友:就是在这几天就是享受就好了
Shure's GF: Just enjoy these few days.
男嘉宾:这个系列
Male Guest: This series
Jack: 这个这个主要得有系列
Jack: This mainly needs a series.
Shure的女友:无所谓
Shure's GF: Whatever
男嘉宾:我到时候可以用这个数据集多多来
Male Guest: I can use this dataset more later.
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry
Jack: 多多多来一次
Jack: More, more, more times.
Katrina: 居然是这样的
Katrina: I can't believe it.
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry
Katrina: 居然是这样子
Katrina: I can't believe it.
Alice:笑死我了
Alice: That kills me.
Shure的女友:邀请你
Shure's GF: Invite you.
男嘉宾:没有没有你谋生哦
Male Guest: No, no, you survive.
Alice:来看一遍
Alice: Let's see it again.
Katrina: 确实北欧男不来
Katrina: Indeed, Nordic men don't come.
Shure的女友:对就是你活动娱乐活动就是怎么讲
Shure's GF: Yeah, your entertainment activities, how to say it...
Katrina: 是北欧男不喜欢然后
Katrina: Nordic men don't like it, and then...
Shure的女友:你这种
Shure's GF: People like you...
男嘉宾:没有没有特别多
Male Guest: Not many
Shure的女友:我来我我来北京
Shure's GF: I come to Beijing.
Jake:很多啦
Jake: A lot.
Lucia:该不知道这种话题的乐趣在哪里
Lucia: I don't understand the fun in these topics.
Shure的女友:我参加一个活动
Shure's GF: I attend an event.
Shure的女友:然后最后一天那个阿弗伦party
Shure's GF: And on the last day, there's an Afren party.
Jake:特别多是啥意思
Jake: What do you mean by a lot?
Jake:你这小地方
Jake: In this small place of yours.
Jake:比这强劲的
Jake: Stronger than this.
Shure的女友:我要邀请一个朋友
Shure's GF: I want to invite a friend.
Jake:几张照片了
Jake: How many photos?
Shure的女友:然后我邀请了你
Shure's GF: Then I invited you.
男嘉宾:还好
Male Guest: It's okay.
Alice:我真的
Alice: I really...
Shure的女友:然后你过来了
Shure's GF: And then you came over.
Shure的女友:这件事情本身来讲
Shure's GF: This whole thing...
男嘉宾:数据
Male Guest: Data.
Jake:七八
Jake: Seven or eight.
Shure的女友:就是一个很暧昧的事情
Shure's GF: ...is actually quite ambiguous.
Alice:为什么你每个视频都这么好笑呢
Alice: Why are all your videos so funny?
男嘉宾:是你们得看那个摄像头里面的啊啊
Male Guest: You guys have to check the camera for that.
Alice:我请问啊
Alice: Can I ask...
女嘉宾:这两个发给你
Female Guest: These two are for you.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:可以
Lucia: Sure.
刘婷:你笑点很低呀
Liu Ting: You have a low threshold for humor.
女嘉宾:这两个还蛮好的嗯
Female Guest: These two are quite good, yeah.
Alice:是吗那别人怎么不这么好笑
Alice: Really? Then why aren't others as funny?
Shure的女友:非常actually
Shure's GF: Very, actually.
女嘉宾:这个在搅搅的
Female Guest: This one is stirring.
Katrina: CPU烧了
Katrina: The CPU burned out.
男嘉宾:因为因为因为只能邀
Male Guest: Because, because, because you can only invite...
男嘉宾:因为因为只能邀你只邀请到了一个
Male Guest: Because, because you can only invite one.
女嘉宾:搅搅哈
Female Guest: Stir it, huh?
男嘉宾:你只邀请到了一个
Male Guest: You could only invite one.
刘婷:我们俩天生一对
Liu Ting: We're a perfect match.
Shure的女友:yeah just one对
Shure's GF: Yeah, just one pair.
男嘉宾:对你只邀请到一个这个是
Male Guest: Yeah, you could only invite one.
男嘉宾:你只邀请到一个
Male Guest: You could only invite one.
Lucia:你可以选针
Lucia: You can choose the needle.
男嘉宾:这个事情就很就很tricky
Male Guest: This thing is very, very tricky.
Lucia:你觉得哪针好看就选哪针
Lucia: Choose whichever needle looks good to you.
Shure: 而且你得回
Shure: And you have to go back.
男嘉宾:邀请的人家
Male Guest: Invite the person.
刘婷:要放几遍
Liu Ting: How many times?
刘婷:我问你要放几遍
Liu Ting: I ask, how many times?
男嘉宾:你邀请不是人家问的你
Male Guest: The invitation isn't what they asked you to do.
Alice:你管我你管我
Alice: Mind your own business.
Shure的女友:对是你是你问他
Shure's GF: Yes, you asked him.
Shure的女友:就是可能对你来讲
Shure's GF: Maybe for you
Shure的女友:你筛选的选项就是啊在北京我认识
Shure's GF: The options you select are like, in Beijing I know
Shure的女友:还可以很熟
Shure's GF: And I'm quite familiar
Shure的女友:然后我可以邀请人
Shure's GF: Then I can invite people
Shure的女友:对他来说就是
Shure's GF: For him, it's like
Shure的女友:对他来说就是哦他邀请我
Shure's GF: For him, it's like, oh, he invites me
Shure的女友:只有一个我要邀请人
Shure's GF: There's only one, I need to invite people
Shure的女友:我邀请人家哇
Shure's GF: I invite others, wow
Jack: 女孩子在国内的语境
Jack: Girls in the domestic context
Jack: 女孩子主动邀请这种选择
Jack: Girls taking the initiative to invite, this choice
Nicous: 而且那个男生他就是在
Nicous: And that guy, he just
Nicous: 他需要的是
Nicous: What he needs is
Shure: 前所未有的数据集
Shure: An unprecedented dataset
Katrina: 我北京我不待几天
Katrina: I won't stay in Beijing for a few days
Katrina: 然后别担心一起见
Katrina: Then don't worry, we'll meet
女嘉宾:我在看他在割双眼皮的一个
Female Guest: I'm watching him getting double eyelid surgery
Katrina: 见个面就不担心
Katrina: Just meet and don't worry
Shure的女友:别担心掉人生了
Shure's GF: Don't worry about life falling apart
Jack: 他现在肯定已经在回去的路上想着
Jack: He's definitely thinking about it on the way back
Lucia:这是什么
Lucia: What is this
女嘉宾:这是他在试验双眼皮
Female Guest: He's experimenting with double eyelids
男嘉宾:到时候回武汉的时候
Male Guest: When I go back to Wuhan
Jake:他有时候是
Jake: Sometimes he is
男嘉宾:我一般去北京西站送
Male Guest: I usually go to Beijing West Station to send off
女嘉宾:但是我看他这个封面区别还是蛮大的
Female Guest: But I see the difference in his cover is quite big
Jake: 点
Jake: Point
男嘉宾:你也是这样的必是这样的
Male Guest: You are also like this, must be like this
Jake: 点
Jake: Point
Nicous: 我也在规划五一去武汉
Nicous: I’m also planning to go to Wuhan on May Day
Alice:紫棠给你看一个
Alice: Zitang will show you something
Nicous: 就是在纠结
Nicous: Just hesitating
Katrina: 他也邀请过我
Katrina: He also invited me
Shure的女友:6666 stop
Shure's GF: 6666 stop
Katrina: 一起去玩
Katrina: Let’s go have fun together
Jack: 卧槽一起出去玩你还要
Jack: Damn, go out and have fun together, you still want to
Alice:弱智视频
Alice: Stupid video
Lucia:是刚才那个吗
Lucia: Is it that one from before
Katrina: 但是我当然是
Katrina: But of course
Katrina: 到时候再说
Katrina: We'll see then
Alice:啊不是吧
Alice: Ah, no way
Nicous: 不是一起出去玩
Nicous: Aren't we going out together?
Alice:我也不知道是不是
Alice: I don't know if we are.
Nicous: 就是很明显很难邀请的
Nicous: It's obviously hard to invite them.
Alice:你看
Alice: Look.
Jake:这很难邀请的
Jake: It's really hard to invite them.
Jake:很难出口的邀请来
Jake: It's difficult to extend the invitation.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
男嘉宾:而且得并没有得到一个你直接否定的
Male Guest: And you didn't get a direct rejection either.
Jack: 怎么说呢
Jack: How do you put it?
Jack: 因为他要求你
Jack: Because he asked you.
女嘉宾:好牛啊
Female Guest: So bold.
Katrina: 因为我觉得拒绝很尴尬
Katrina: Because I think rejecting is awkward.
Alice:笑死
Alice: That's hilarious.
Lucia:好牛啊
Lucia: So bold.
Katrina: 就是大家是很好的朋友
Katrina: I mean, we're all good friends.
Jack: 男女生朋友单独一点
Jack: Guy and girl friends, a bit alone.
Jack: 但感觉就是就是从那个他的视角
Jack: But it feels like, from his perspective.
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Shure的女友:他可能从从女孩子视角来讲
Sister: He might be speaking from a girl's perspective.
Lucia:就是有点冷
Lucia: It's a bit cold.
Lucia:但是真的很搞笑
Lucia: But it's really funny.
Lucia:你们多加几个关键词我觉得会火
Lucia: Add a few more keywords, it'll go viral.
Shure的女友:不要担心任何事情
Sister: Don't worry about anything.
Shure的女友:你给他吊就行了
Sister: Just lead him on.
Alice:刘婷 又跑哪去了
Alice: Where did Liu Ting run off to again?
Shure的女友:为什么男生有这个特征
Sister: Why do guys have this trait?
Shure的女友:女生也可以有啊
Sister: Girls can have it too.
Shure的女友:whatever
Sister: Whatever.
Lucia:然后大家就会争模拍
Lucia: Then everyone will be fighting to be in the picture.
Shure的女友:吊就行了我喜欢
Sister: Just lead him on, I like it.
Alice:她每天都在这样 每天
Alice: She does this every day, every single day.
Shure的女友:你开心就好
Sister: As long as you're happy.
男嘉宾:就当天晚上
Male Guest: That very night.
男嘉宾:这不是正常吗
Male Guest: Isn't that normal?
Jack: 当天就有这么好的吗
Jack: Was it that good that very night?
Shure: 别我害怕
Shure: No, I'm scared.
Jack: 过夜啊对啊
Jack: Stayed overnight, right?
Jack: 当天就到这份上了
Jack: It got to that point that night.
Shure: 要不我们三个
Shure: How about the three of us?
Shure: 不要不要
Shure: No, no.
女嘉宾:抖音那个视频发给你了
Female Guest: I sent you that TikTok video.
Shure的女友:就是咱俩现在分手
Sister: So, we're breaking up now.
Shure的女友:我猜不来吧来斯宾
Sister: I guess I can't come to Spain.
Alice:不是咱俩那那能看吗
Alice: Can we even see it?
Shure的女友:OK
Sister: OK.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 哈哈哈这不是重点
Shure: Hahaha, that's not the point.
Jake:就预约了
Jake: Just made an appointment.
Jake:就是
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 但是我肯定不会跟他单独去啊
Katrina: But I definitely won't go alone with him.
Katrina: 那当时就是拒绝什么的
Katrina: I just refused at the time.
Lucia:再来点
Lucia: A bit more.
Katrina: 因为不好接受啊
Katrina: Because it's hard to accept.
Katrina: 我说我当时跟他去他真提出来这个
Katrina: I said if I went with him and he really brought it up...
Jake:invitation就这个invitation
Jake: The invitation, just this invitation.
Alice:嘿嘿嘿 下班了吗 累
Alice: Hehehe, done for the day? Tired.
Lucia:对就说明他预期在出去玩之前
Lucia: Yeah, it means he expected it before going out.
Jake:太BIOS
Jake: Too biased.
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
Shure的女友:不是我在想我就好受欢迎
Sister: No, I was just thinking, I'm so popular.
Alice:我想上厕所
Alice: I need to use the bathroom.
Jake:今天又邀请来了
Jake: Invited again today.
Jake:不一样了给你说
Jake: It's different, I'm telling you.
Alice:你给我看个门
Alice: Watch the door for me.
Shure: 你怎么每天就是照着镜子我好美
Shure: How come every day you're just looking in the mirror saying, "I'm so beautiful."
Shure: 然后晚上我好受欢迎
Shure: And at night, "I'm so popular."
刘婷:去吧
Liu Ting: Go ahead.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Lucia:我突然觉得这个
Lucia: Suddenly, I think this...
Alice:走
Alice: Let's go.
Lucia:这个白板配上这个包挺好看的
Lucia: This whiteboard and the bag look good together.
Jake:那
Jake: Then...
Alice:给我看着门 刘婷
Alice: Watch the door for me, Liu Ting.
Shure的女友:别担心知道现在爱着你
Sister: Don't worry, I know he loves you now.
Lucia:这个决定拍一下
Lucia: Let's take a picture of this decision.
Shure: 至少现在
Shure: At least now...
Alice:啊 好累啊今天
Alice: Ah, so tired today.
Shure: 今天 可以了
Shure: Today, it's enough.
Shure: 你这定位加的有点多
Shure: You added a bit too much location data.
Alice:给我看着门 啊
Alice: Watch the door for me, ah.
刘婷:行
Liu Ting: Okay
Alice:顺便再给我看着眼镜
Alice: By the way, keep an eye on my glasses.
Alice:别让人给我偷了
Alice: Don't let anyone steal them.
Alice:偷了也没事
Alice: Even if they do, it's fine.
刘婷:你看这周多少
Liu Ting: Look at this week's amount.
Alice:防的就是你家贼难防
Alice: The hardest thing to guard against is a thief from your own home.
Alice:哇哦
Alice: Wow
Alice:禁止偷看
Alice: No peeking allowed.
男嘉宾:尽是箱子
Male Guest: Just boxes everywhere.
Alice:等着我怎么收拾你
Alice: Just wait and see how I'll deal with you.
Alice:哈哈哈你要干什么
Alice: Hahaha, what are you trying to do?
Alice:以死先罪
Alice: Dying to be guilty first.
Alice:要带它
Alice: Gotta take it.
Katrina: 大家都没有考虑这是什么啊
Katrina: Has anyone thought about what this is?
刘婷:所以你的更多内容就是
Liu Ting: So your additional content is just
刘婷:带着他去进行人类活动
Liu Ting: taking him to do human activities?
刘婷:是吗
Liu Ting: Right?
Alice:yes
Alice: Yes.
刘婷:下回实在不行整个有兜的
Liu Ting: Next time, if it really doesn't work, get one with pockets.
Alice:我没兜这个裙实在是没兜
Alice: I don't have pockets; this dress really doesn't have pockets.
Shure的女友:没有一点关系
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter at all.
Katrina: 我要我要
Katrina: I want it, I want it.
Katrina: 喜欢的话我第一眼喜欢就是喜欢
Katrina: If I like it at first sight, I just like it.
男嘉宾:那你下次就告诉他你下次就告诉他
Male Guest: Then next time, just tell him, next time, just tell him.
男嘉宾:就说你就说
Male Guest: Just say, just say
男嘉宾:我我我喜欢我喜欢的人
Male Guest: I, I like, I like the person I like.
刘婷:你想一下我惊人的拍摄技术吧
Liu Ting: Think about my amazing filming skills.
Lucia:啊这个是
Lucia: Ah, this is
Alice:你是不是卖牙线棒来着
Alice: Are you selling dental floss sticks?
Alice:你能给我顺一根吗
Alice: Can you give me one?
Alice:好像卡东西了
Alice: Seems like something's stuck.
刘婷:压线棒不是在你那个
Liu Ting: Aren't the dental floss sticks with your
刘婷:朋友那吗
Liu Ting: friend?
刘婷:忘了
Liu Ting: Forgot.
Alice:哦啊 为什么是她 她拿走了
Alice: Oh, why her? She took them.
Alice:你就不能给我留两根
Alice: Couldn't you leave me two?
Alice:咱俩就坐那乘凉
Alice: Let's just sit there and enjoy the breeze.
Lucia:我特别的哎呀乘凉
Lucia: I'm really, oh, enjoying the breeze.
刘婷：可以
Liu Ting: Sure.
Alice:咱俩退休以后也能这样坐着
Alice: We could sit like this after we retire too.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
刘婷：退休以后
Liu Ting: After we retire.
Jake:对一天一千五
Jake: Yeah, 1500 a day.
Lucia:没事放心就是就是
Lucia: No worries, just relax.
Lucia:我比如说跟别人合照的话
Lucia: For example, if I take photos with others.
Jake:可以去三亚
Jake: We could go to Sanya.
Lucia:就是朋友同一个情况下我才发
Lucia: I only post if my friends are in the same photo.
Alice:她家有
Alice: She has it at home.
Jake:哦真的啊
Jake: Oh really?
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:那下回到他家拍
Jake: Then we'll take photos at her place next time.
Lucia:所以就是我的懒主要体现在
Lucia: So, my laziness shows in that.
Lucia:就是如果我朋友没P我就不P也不发了就
Lucia: If my friends don't edit the photos, I won't either, and just won't post them.
刘婷:咱们这还有下一回
Liu Ting: Are we really having another go?
Jake:哈哈哈万一呢
Jake: Haha, just in case.
女嘉宾:我就哈哈哈错过下次错过
Female Guest: Haha, missing out next time, missing out.
Jake:万一有下回
Jake: Just in case there's a next time.
Shure的女友:胶片感
Shure: Film vibe.
Shure的女友:但是你拍胶片要爱的毕竟胶片
Shure: But you need to love it to shoot film, after all, film...
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia:如果我
Lucia: If I...
Alice:深藏不露哼
Alice: Hidden talent, huh?
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Alice:有小别墅你不告诉我
Alice: You have a small villa and didn't tell me.
Shure的女友:我们我们前几天去了趟河北
Shure: We, we went to Hebei a few days ago.
刘婷:没有他也是就是这种
Liu Ting: No, he's just like that.
Shure的女友:然后我带了一个一次性的胶片
Shure: And I brought a disposable film camera.
Jake:那就我呢
Jake: What about me?
Jake:在哪啊
Jake: Where is it?
Shure的女友:就整个胶片拍出来
Shure: The whole film was developed.
Shure的女友:感觉除了被手指挡到的那部分
Shure: Except for the parts blocked by fingers.
Lucia:啥呀 啥呀
Lucia: What? What?
Jake: 她说她家
Jake: She said her house.
Alice:她家
Alice: Her house.
Alice:他家有这个这样的小院子
Alice: Her house has a small yard like this.
Shure的女友:所有照片都是原图指出的
Shure: All the photos are straight out of the camera.
Alice:他不告诉我啊
Alice: And she didn't tell me.
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:刘婷你天天的
Alice: Liu Ting, you do this every day.
Jake:在哪在哪
Jake: Where, where?
刘婷:在昌平那边昌平
Liu Ting: In Changping, over in Changping.
Jake: 昌平
Jake: Changping.
Alice:昌平
Alice: Changping.
Jake: 噢
Jake: Oh.
Alice:那有大型超市吗
Alice: Are there any big supermarkets there?
刘婷:嗯附近吗
Liu Ting: Hmm, nearby?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
刘婷:嗯得开车
Liu Ting: Hmm, you’d have to drive.
Alice:多多远的车
Alice: How far by car?
Jake: 咱也开车
Jake: We’ll drive too.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia:哎哎
Lucia: Hey, hey.
Shure: 这个灯到点会自己灭
Shure: This light turns off by itself.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia:怎么突然断电了
Lucia: Why did the power suddenly cut off?
女嘉宾:9点半
Female Guest: 9:30.
Jake:他 他真讲究
Jake: He’s really particular.
Jake:九点半
Jake: 9:30.
Lucia:才九点半哎
Lucia: It’s only 9:30.
Lucia:好过份 至少也要十一点断电吧
Lucia: So unfair, at least cut the power at 11.
Alice:你在瞎录啥呢
Alice: What are you randomly recording?
女嘉宾:可是我发现啊
Female Guest: But I found that...
刘婷:就是这个
Liu Ting: It’s just this...
刘婷:其实你昌平在哪边
Liu Ting: Actually, where in Changping are you?
刘婷:其实你你就是拍你拍视频
Liu Ting: Actually, you’re just recording, recording videos.
Lucia:昌平在哪边
Lucia: Where in Changping?
刘婷:然后之后截图
Liu Ting: Then take a screenshot.
刘婷:他会比原来的色彩更还原一点
Liu Ting: The colors will be more accurate than before.
Alice:那你亮灯的时候不拍
Alice: Why not record with the lights on?
Alice:你这一灯一灭你在这拍啥
Alice: The lights turn off and you’re still recording?
刘婷:我刚摆上灯就灭了
Liu Ting: I just set up the lights and they turned off.
Alice:我刚拍上灯就灭了
Alice: I just started recording and the lights turned off.
Alice:你呢
Alice: What about you?
Lucia:我在北京的活动轨迹
Lucia: My activity in Beijing...
Lucia:就只有从我们学校那边
Lucia: is only from our school area...
刘婷:晚上像两只鬼啊
Liu Ting: At night, like two ghosts.
Lucia:就五道口那里到
Lucia: just from Wudaokou to...
Alice:你说你是鬼就可以了 你带上我干嘛
Alice: It’s fine if you say you’re a ghost, why drag me into it?
Lucia:对大概连线到天安门
Lucia: Yes, roughly connecting to Tiananmen.
Lucia:就这一条线上
Lucia: It's on this line.
Alice:我请问呢
Alice: May I ask?
Lucia:然后呢哈哈
Lucia: And then, haha.
Alice:你把你手机流量调调高呗
Alice: Can you increase your phone data?
Lucia:也去但是去的很少
Lucia: Yeah, but I rarely go.
刘婷:这个有用吗
Liu Ting: Is this useful?
Lucia:然后我实习的时候会去国贸这边
Lucia: During my internship, I would go to Guomao.
Alice:嗯 有用啊
Alice: Yeah, it is.
Lucia:金台西照这里
Lucia: Jintai Xizhao area.
Shure的女友:我们要讲些商业机密
Sister: We need to discuss some business secrets.
Lucia:东边最远我大概就到这
Lucia: The furthest east I've been is here.
Lucia:然后除了对除了那阵就是打杂的时候
Lucia: Except for when I was just doing odd jobs.
刘婷:哎你别说你真别说
Liu Ting: Hey, don't say it, really don't.
Lucia:就是来黄泉城的那个
Lucia: Like when I went to Huangquancheng.
刘婷:哦
Liu Ting: Oh.
Alice:搞笑
Alice: Funny.
Lucia:就是拍片子打过杂嘛
Lucia: I did odd jobs on a film set.
Lucia:然后来过化妆这里
Lucia: Then went to the makeup area.
Lucia:就基本上咱们这了就来过一次
Lucia: Basically, I only came here once.
刘婷:嗯
Liu Ting: Hmm.
Lucia:然后其他的最远最远我就到国贸
Lucia: The farthest I've been is Guomao.
刘婷:算了
Liu Ting: Forget it.
刘婷:拍照拍的确实不咋地
Liu Ting: The photos are really not great.
Jake: 没问题 我靠
Jake: No problem, damn it.
Lucia:对我们进去了
Lucia: Yeah, we went in.
Lucia:但当时还没有正式营业
Lucia: But it wasn't officially open yet.
Lucia:所以就没有在里面玩过 对
Lucia: So we didn't get to play inside.
Lucia:然后
Lucia: Then...
Lucia:所以我对北京的很多地方
Lucia: So, many places in Beijing...
Lucia:其实都不是很熟悉
Lucia: I'm actually not familiar with.
Lucia:因为太大了就没去过
Lucia: Because it's so big and I haven't been.
Lucia:对对对我现在是托了就是我
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, now it's because of me...
Alice:你们是长租出去还是一天一租
Alice: Do you rent long-term or daily?
Lucia:上本科最后一年
Lucia: In my final year of undergrad.
Jake: 没有 0% 这这这沟
Jake: No, 0%. This, this, this...
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
刘婷:长租啊
Liu Ting: Long-term.
Jake:你们沟就这样是吗
Jake: You communicate like this?
刘婷:团队包的
Liu Ting: It's a team package.
Lucia:对前三年一个就不太 是的
Lucia: Yeah, the first three years were not really... yes.
刘婷:嗯员工宿舍
Liu Ting: Hmm, the employee dormitory.
Lucia:就一个课会多一些嘛
Lucia: One class had more things.
Lucia:然后也不是很想去
Lucia: And I didn't really want to go.
Alice:一年多少钱
Alice: How much per year?
Lucia:就学校太大了就很麻烦
Lucia: The school is too big, it's very inconvenient.
刘婷:一年
Liu Ting: Per year.
Shure的女友:交钱 给你拍了多少照片
Shure's GF: How much did you pay for all those photos?
Lucia:因为我们要骑自行车才能出学校
Lucia: We had to ride bikes to leave the school.
Lucia:然后
Lucia: And...
Lucia:然后而且那个地铁站离我们校门还远
Lucia: And the subway station is far from our school gate.
刘婷:一年也不是很贵吧
Liu Ting: It's not very expensive per year, right?
Lucia:然后所以就是
Lucia: So...
刘婷:好像六七万块钱
Liu Ting: Seems like 60-70 thousand.
Lucia:除非是去实习或者之类中不得不去了
Lucia: Unless it's for an internship or something, I wouldn't go.
Alice:两层吗
Alice: Two floors?
Lucia:否则都不会去的
Lucia: Otherwise, I wouldn't go.
刘婷:嗯两层
Liu Ting: Yeah, two floors.
Alice:那确实不贵
Alice: That's not expensive.
Lucia:然后我就一直拖到这一年快毕业了
Lucia: So I kept delaying until this year, almost graduating.
Alice:这一天两千啊
Alice: That's 2,000 a day.
Lucia:然后我看好像有一些景点还没去
Lucia: Then I realized there were some places I hadn't visited.
Lucia:我就把景点打卡了一下
Lucia: So I checked off those places.
刘婷:这不会就是因为这离环球影城近吧
Liu Ting: Is it because it's close to Universal Studios?
Jake:七七个 7台相机
Jake: Seven cameras.
Alice:这好像这一片你看都是小别墅都是因为
Alice: It seems like this area is full of small villas because...
Lucia:所以有就好地方不太熟
Lucia: So I wasn't really familiar with good places.
Jake:回头那个网页专门给你整一份
Jake: I'll make a special webpage for you later.
Alice:环球然后他们改的
Alice: They changed it.
刘婷:我刚才看里面还有个地盘
Liu Ting: I saw there's a place inside.
Lucia:在国贸附近具体哪个路段
Lucia: Near Guomao, but I forgot the exact section.
刘婷:然后说是那个什么不含门票
Liu Ting: They said it doesn't include the ticket.
Lucia:我忘记了但它就那一片
Lucia: I forgot, but it's in that area.
Lucia:因为因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia:就是其实
Lucia: Actually...
刘婷:就是代那个代玩
Liu Ting: It's like a guided tour.
Lucia:比如说招人的公司大部分都在那个
Lucia: Most hiring companies are there.
刘婷:就说代玩个
Liu Ting: They offer guided tours.
刘婷:项目啊估计就是什么
Liu Ting: Projects, I guess.
刘婷:我感觉像带排队那种业务之类的
Liu Ting: I think it's like a queue service or something.
刘婷:就是
Liu Ting: So,
Alice:差不多吧
Alice: Almost, yeah.
刘婷:走快递通道那种吧
Liu Ting: Like using the express channel, right?
刘婷:便宜的
Liu Ting: The cheaper one.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
刘婷:不含门票
Liu Ting: Doesn't include tickets.
刘婷:一位288 贵的1千多
Liu Ting: It's 288 per person, the expensive one is over 1000.
Lucia:他其实给120一天
Lucia: He actually gives 120 a day.
Alice:有那么好玩吗
Alice: Is it really that fun?
刘婷:图什么呢
Liu Ting: What's the point?
Katrina: 觉得自己不要自作多情
Katrina: Don't flatter yourself.
刘婷:不就是拍照打卡吗
Liu Ting: Isn't it just for taking pictures and checking in?
Lucia:对哈哈
Lucia: Exactly, haha.
刘婷:我天呐
Liu Ting: Oh my god.
女嘉宾:东北话那个气味
Female Guest: That northeastern accent.
Lucia:对对对真的是
Lucia: Yeah, totally.
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Alice:你在聊什么
Alice: What are you talking about?
Katrina: 为什么要发啊
Katrina: Why send it?
Alice:工作吗啊
Alice: Work stuff?
我们在说之前是
We were talking about before.
Lucia:啊我们在说之前实习的时候
Lucia: Ah, we were talking about our internship before.
男嘉宾:不是我给男生发
Male Guest: No, I send it to the guys.
男嘉宾:对男生会发
Male Guest: Yeah, I send it to the guys.
男嘉宾:就每个人不一样
Male Guest: It's different for everyone.
男嘉宾:就是每个人那个艺人的方向不一样
Male Guest: Everyone's career path is different.
Alice:你真的好亮
Alice: You're really shiny.
Alice:这个我是不是也很亮
Alice: Am I shiny too?
男嘉宾:这不好拍
Male Guest: It's hard to photograph well.
Lucia:是的
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:很明显
Alice: Very obvious.
男嘉宾:挺好瞎处置
Male Guest: Just deal with it casually.
Alice:巨明显
Alice: Super obvious.
Alice:脸上长了个星星一样哎
Alice: It's like a star on your face.
男嘉宾:你就等他说吧
Male Guest: Just let him talk.
Lucia:好酷时尚单品
Lucia: Cool fashion accessory.
刘婷:你有狼的眼睛
Liu Ting: You have wolf eyes.
男嘉宾:就按照现在
Male Guest: Just as it is now.
Nicous: 主要还是长太漂亮了
Nicous: Mainly because you're too pretty.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:你每次都能
Alice: You always
刘婷:你别听就好了
Liu Ting: Just don't listen
Alice:把一件炫酷性感的事情
Alice: Make something cool and sexy
Alice:描述的像一个发情母猩猩
Alice: Sound like a horny female gorilla
女嘉宾:但我最近就跟他们聊了
Female Guest: But I just talked to them recently
刘婷:OK你不要听就行
Liu Ting: OK, just don't listen
Lucia:那我应该会看一下
Lucia: Then I should take a look
Lucia:有偶像包袱
Lucia: Having an image burden
Nicous: 没事今天我给他搭回去啊
Nicous: No worries, I'll take him back today
Lucia:哈哈哈不多但有一点
Lucia: Haha, not much, but a little
Katrina: 反正我是觉得就是来北京
Katrina: Anyway, I think coming to Beijing
Lucia:对 因为
Lucia: Yes, because
Nicous: 今天给他搭回去
Nicous: I'll take him back today
Alice:我想睡觉 婷
Alice: I want to sleep, Ting
Alice:喔
Nicous: 回到100%的草药版
Nicous: Back to 100% herbal version
Lucia:啊他就会定位出来
Lucia: Ah, he'll pinpoint it
Alice:没掉
Lucia:啊好厉害
Lucia: Ah, so impressive
Alice:没事充电宝不值钱
Alice: No power bank, not valuable
Alice:眼镜值钱
Alice: Glasses are valuable
Jake:你这抗遗忘曲线挺挺挺棒的
Jake: Your anti-forgetting curve is pretty great
Jake:我靠 越来越稳
Jake: Wow, getting steadier
Jake:哈哈哈抗遗忘曲线你知道吧
Jake: Haha, you know the anti-forgetting curve, right?
刘婷:你们平常
Liu Ting: You guys usually
刘婷:你前几天
Liu Ting: The other day you
刘婷:你们你们前几天
Liu Ting: You guys, the other day you
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
刘婷:录到多晚啊大概
Liu Ting: How late did you record until roughly?
Shure: 人民教师了
Shure: A people's teacher
Alice:快12点 有的时候
Alice: Almost midnight, sometimes
Lucia:哈哈哈这样子
Lucia: Hahaha, like this
刘婷:那你睡的够晚的呀
Liu Ting: Then you sleep pretty late
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm
Alice:是啊
Alice: Yeah
Shure: 什么钱什么钱啊
Shure: What money, what money?
Alice:10点10点都算早了
Alice: 10 o'clock, 10 o'clock is early
Alice:11点12点
Alice: 11 or 12 o'clock
Shure: 刮刮吧
Shure: Scratch it
Alice:咋了 困了吗
Alice: What's up, sleepy?
Shure: 你看我能能刮多长就全转过去好不好
Shure: Look, if I can scrape it all off, can we turn it all the way around?
Lucia:噢 好神奇
Lucia: Oh, that's amazing.
Lucia:他就会发现我经常在吃东西
Lucia: He'll find out that I'm always eating.
Lucia:然后在摸鱼
Lucia: And slacking off.
刘婷:9:30
Liu Ting: 9:30
Alice:还有多少story
Alice: How many stories are left?
刘婷:跟我看知否吧
Liu Ting: Watch "The Story of Minglan" with me.
Alice:还有20多个GB
Alice: Still over 20 GB left.
Alice:老板呢
Alice: Where's the boss?
刘婷:在屋里
Liu Ting: In the room.
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 但是那个
Katrina: But that...
Alice:可以可以关了吗
Alice: Can we turn it off now?
Lucia:对 我也会
Lucia: Right, I also will.
Alice:你还有多少story
Alice: How many stories do you have left?
Lucia:我看一眼
Lucia: Let me check.
Lucia:我中间好像断了一次
Lucia: I think I had a break in between.
Alice:感觉有点困了
Alice: I'm feeling a bit sleepy.
男嘉宾:觉得你好看不
Male Guest: Do you think you're good-looking?
Lucia:我竟然还有41G
Lucia: I still have 41GB left.
Shure的女友:因为觉得你好看
Shure's GF: Because I think you're good-looking.
Alice:我28
Alice: I have 28GB.
Shure的女友:对觉得你好看
Shure's GF: Yeah, I think you're good-looking.
Alice:唉 紫棠你今天在这住吗
Alice: Hey, Violet, are you staying here tonight?
Lucia:那可能是因为我中间断了
Lucia: Maybe because I had a break in between.
Alice:你今天在这住吗
Alice: Are you staying here tonight?
Alice:那你 这是不是
Alice: So, is this...
Shure: 这这个话说的
Shure: This, this is what I said.
Alice:你回去不是就很晚了
Alice: If you go back, it will be very late.
Lucia:那你是不是要回去 因为9.30了
Lucia: So, are you going back? Because it's 9:30.
Shure的女友:你现在觉得哦OK
Shure's GF: Do you feel okay now?
Alice:要不然你今天晚上住在这里吧
Alice: Why don't you stay here tonight?
Shure的女友:哪个男生不喜欢我
Shure's GF: Which guy doesn't like me?
Shure的女友:你可能就是陷入了一些南宁的视角
Shure's GF: You might be caught up in some perspective from Nanning.
Alice:我们女生很多可以住
Alice: We have many girls who can stay.
Alice:对非常不了解
Alice: Yeah, very unfamiliar.
Shure的女友:但是你无所谓怎么样
Shure's GF: But you don't care anyway.
Nicous: 确实 我赞成
Nicous: Indeed, I agree.
Nicous: 有没有可能有没有可能
Nicous: Is it possible, is it possible...
Shure的女友:就当OK我我是最好看的一个
Shure's GF: Just assume I'm the best-looking one.
Alice:主要是有点晚了
Alice: It's mainly because it's a bit late.
Lucia:是的
Lucia: Yeah.
Shure的女友:无所谓他们不喜欢我就是他们
Shure's GF: Whatever, if they don't like me, that's their problem.
Nicous: 有没有可能他
Nicous: Could it be possible that he...
Tasha:了解的有47%
Tasha: 47% of people understand.
Shure的女友:他们他们眼睛有问题
Shure's GF: They have vision problems.
Shure的女友:无所谓我是这么
Shure's GF: Whatever, I'm like this.
Nicous: 有没有可能
Nicous: Could it be possible...
Nicous: 有没有很好的啊
Nicous: Could it be great...
Nicous: 就是因为喜欢你
Nicous: Because he likes you...
Nicous: 真的喜欢你的
Nicous: He really likes you.
Nicous: 这不很正常吗
Nicous: Isn't that normal?
Katrina: 我我对我自己
Katrina: I, I for myself...
Katrina: 就是我不会容貌就是我不要应该喜欢
Katrina: I won't tolerate my appearance, I shouldn't like...
Shure的女友:不要对你自己这样
Shure's GF: Don't be like that to yourself.
Katrina: 但是我
Katrina: But I...
Shure的女友:你对你自己
Shure's GF: You to yourself...
Shure的女友:你对你自己整个人感觉就是啊OK
Shure's GF: You feel like the whole world doesn't like you.
Shure的女友:整个世界都不喜欢我的人
Shure's GF: The whole world doesn't like me.
Jack: 坏了开始开始开始
Jack: Oh no, let's start, start, start.
Nicous: 这个指导
Nicous: This guidance...
Katrina: 因为我很害怕
Katrina: Because I'm scared.
男嘉宾:而且你生日都生日
Male Guest: And your birthday, birthday...
男嘉宾:都不用管人家喜不喜欢你
Male Guest: Don't worry about whether people like you.
男嘉宾:跟你有什么关系呢
Male Guest: What's that got to do with you?
Jack: 对啊
Jack: Yeah.
Shure的女友:是啊
Shure's GF: Yeah.
Katrina: 所以今天我对
Katrina: So today I...
Nicous: 所以他就是喜欢你
Nicous: So he just likes you.
Lucia:添加一下还没有加的同学的好友好了
Lucia: Let's add the friends we haven't added yet.
Shure的女友:他他喜欢就OK啦
Shure's GF: If he likes you, it's okay.
Lucia:哈哈哈我看看是谁
Lucia: Haha, let me see who it is.
Shure的女友:就是你你你
Shure's GF: It's you, you, you.
Lucia:我还没加
Lucia: I haven't added yet.
Katrina: 但是当我就是遇到了他喜欢我的时候
Katrina: But when I meet someone who likes me...
Lucia:董宇浩同学
Lucia: Dong Yuhao.
Nicous: 我就会考虑他为什么
Nicous: I would consider why he...
Shure的女友:你喜欢他也无所谓
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter if you like him.
Shure的女友:他喜欢你也无所谓
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter if he likes you.
Shure的女友:就是你做你自己就好了
Shure's GF: Just be yourself.
Lucia:给他发送一下
Lucia: Send it to him
Shure的女友:他喜不喜欢你就他现在
Shure: Does he like you now?
Alice:走吧咱回去吧
Alice: Let's go, let's head back
Nicous: 他现在主要点
Nicous: The main point now is
Shure的女友:你不要内耗
Shure: Don't get consumed by it
Nicous: 他的点在于为什么
Nicous: His point is why
Katrina: 为什么喜欢我
Katrina: Why does he like me
Alice:冲冲冲
Alice: Go go go
Nicous: 他的点就在于为什么我们俩在群里
Nicous: His point is why are we both in the group
Alice:没干
Alice: Didn't do anything
Nicous: 为什么一聊天
Nicous: Why do we start talking
Shure的女友:你多有趣你足够好看
Shure: You're interesting enough, you're good looking
Alice:老板嘞
Alice: Boss
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Alice:可以收工吗
Alice: Can we call it a day?
Jake:呃我 收工 收工 收工吧
Jake: Uh, I... let's call it a day, call it a day
Alice:有点不太
Alice: It's a bit...
Jake:收工 收工 收工吧
Jake: Let's wrap it up, wrap it up
Alice:嗯 还有20多
Alice: Hmm, there's still over 20...
Jake:行行行
Jake: Alright, alright
Jake:好收工了收工了
Jake: Okay, it's a wrap, it's a wrap
Alice:收工
Alice: Wrapping up
刘婷：天气怎么不显示
Liu Ting: Why isn't the weather showing up?
Alice:我要卸妆 哈
Alice: I'm going to take off my makeup, haha
Alice:哈
Alice: Haha